[Music]
good afternoon everyone my name is Ben
and I'm cackled CTO Tekel is building a
platform for you to do all your data
science analytics and machine learning
projects in both collaborate on those
amongst ourselves among small teams as
well as share those publicly with the
world but before I get started and
talking about in Des Moines coggle I
want to get a bit of a better
understanding of who you are and how
familiar you are with cago so let's have
a quick show of hands for a couple
questions first raise your hands if
you've heard of cackle before awesome
this will make this easy almost everyone
asks keep her hands up if you have a
tackle account okay looks like about
half the room keep your hands up if
you've used a cackle data set before
used to data from cackle looks like
we're dropping some hands maybe 10% of
you okay hopefully in the next week
that'll be a hundred percent then keep
your hands up if you've made a
submission to a cackle competition I
must know it one person two people okay
then finally keep your hands up if
you've used cackle Cardinals or our
hosts a notebook product I think two or
three people cool so let's go to and get
start and swap to my screen this session
is going to be entirely demo based I
figure you're going to be seeing a lot
of slideshows and presentations over the
next couple days and I love you sue I
might be biased but I love using our
product so I thought I'd give this
session entirely as a demo and walk you
through the different parts of cackle
I'd also love this session to be a bit
more interactive so if at any point in
time you have a question or you want to
me to talk about something else there
looks like two microphones on either
side of the room you can walk over to
one of those masks or just raise your
hand get my attention they've been
shouted down to me I'll repeat your
question so everyone can hear when you
log into a cog okay the first thing that
you see is a newsfeed of all the public
activity that
going on in cattle and you'll see that
there's a really kind of rich array of
comments about and code being shared on
data analytics and machine learning this
is because we have a community of nearly
two million users and there are all of
whom are people who want to learn more
about data and who love using data in
some capacity and there's cut four core
parts of our platform if there's
competitions we see these in the header
competitions which is where we got
started it's a place for organizations
ranging from commercial users to
nonprofits to research groups to publish
supervised machine learning problems
through coggle in a way that our
community competes to develop the best
solution on those problems that's where
we got started about a decade ago and is
our oldest product we also have goggle
data sets our public data platform which
has about 8,000 data sets that have been
shared with the world on how that you
can go and consuming these cover a huge
range of different topics from
cryptocurrencies and financial data sets
to tweets of different people to a bunch
of computer vision data sets the third
core part of our platform Chicago
kernels which is hosted to pure you know
books and we'll dive add to that in a
much more detail in a little bit and
then finally since many of our new users
come to us to learn to improve their
skills with analytics and machine
learning we really recently launched a
new section of Cagle called learn which
is a set of short bite-sized tutorials
to make it really fast and easy to get
started with analytics and machine
learning and teach you just enough to
get you off the ground and let you start
working on your own projects and diving
into your own projects is really the
fastest and most effective ways to learn
how to apply machine learning and
improve your skills there so to kick off
we'll dive into competitions we click
into the competitions I see all the
active competition
so we have on this site right now that
have large price monies sponsoring them
and just to give you a sense of the
array of different competitions the
first one I see here is on identifying
salt deposits between the Earth's
surface this is a really important
problem for the energy industry and well
and gas exploration and drilling in that
seismic data sets are both very large
and are very challenging to identify
what's the salt deposits in those as
well as more of the underlying
geological structures the next two here
are both with the financial services
industry
the first is focused on home credit
default risks so can you predict the
likelihood of alpha can't repaying their
home loan then the second is with
suntanned air bank on predicting the
value that transactions of potential
customers will bring for them the fourth
competitions actually with Google ai and
it's a complex object detection problem
so focusing on identifying dozens of
different objects in an image and
identifying where those are what the
objects are as well as where they are in
the image and then finally on the
research side the fifth one that we have
shown is with CERN and it's on applying
machine learning to improve our ability
to track particles in the Large Hadron
Collider so you really see from this I
have the range of different applications
that we currently are applying machine
learning to and you we're exposing these
problems to the world I'll click into
one of these to go into a bit more
detail so this is the home credit
default risk competition which is a
$70,000 competition where we've released
an anonymized data set here of a lot of
information on loan applicants and as
you look through this every machine
learning problem starts with rich and
hopefully high-quality data set you'll
see many of the things that you'd
xpect I can click through here and I see
that we've split it off into a train set
that you can use to train a machine
learning model on for the different
applications and then a tough set that
we use to evaluate then score how the
machine learning model is storing if I
scroll down a bit farther I can see rich
data visualization here
that's a nice preview of what's in this
data set you'll see some of the usual
suspects like income what type of loaner
they're looking for and things like that
as well as you'll see that beloved data
that can be helpful for predicting the
likelihood that they already pay they're
alone for example what is the credit
card balance and what other foot loans
do they have out and things along those
lines then you see here that five
thousand people have participated in
this competition so far that is one of
the really unique things about being
able to oppose a machine learning
problem publicly it's the difference
between having one group of people are
small couple teams collaborating on the
problem and having five thousand people
from our on the world be able to focus
on the same problem and with collaborate
and compete to get the best possible
result on that and this five thousand
teams is interest from the US they're
not just people who have machine
learning PhDs from Stanford instead
they'll include things like English
major in us from a school in Germany or
or as hired physicists who want
something that's more entertaining to do
with his free time from Sudoku so it's a
really diverse in international
participants that really helps to
democratize both the raw data and
machine learning problems as well as the
ability to apply this technology to
everyone around the globe
if I click through to our discussion
forums I'll see that there's a really
rich array of discussion on this problem
that's really it in depth in depth looks
at specific considerations in
structuring the system machine learning
problem ain't cleaning the data and what
methods tend to work well on this
problem and things like that where the
community is helping each other out then
I can also see how everyone is currently
doing in this problem by clicking
through to a leaderboard and I'll see
here the score of how people are doing
on this problem in this case users are
predicting the likelihood of person
paying back a load and this is scored
using a machine learning metric called
at the area under the receiver operator
characteristic curve or a you see where
0.5 is random and 1.0 is perfect and
then um you see here that the top teams
are clustered very close together we
have to look in the third decimal or
third digit to see a difference between
many of the different top teams this is
one of the things that we see from
having many different groups around the
world independently working on the same
problem they really find all the signal
that's present in the prom and the rest
tends to be noise that's either inherent
to the data set itself or beyond their
current state-of-the-art machine
learning to handle so let's say I want
to get started on this problem myself
how would I go about that the first
thing we need to do is get access to the
data and there's a couple different ways
they could do that I can click download
and download the data and start working
locally we have an API as well I could
run a command line command to pull the
data down I could also use a new tool
that we developed called Kaggle kernels
I can drop in click new kernel here and
what's going on behind the scenes right
now is in a Google cloud VM I have and
in a docker container within that VM a
new trip tour notebook instance is being
created for me and in this instance
isn't just a vanilla python instance and
said it has both the data
preloaded into it as well as all the
libraries that I may want to use and as
a quick example of that I'll go and give
this a title again import pandas which
is a really nice library for reading in
and working manipulating tabular data
I have things like tensorflow
pre-installed I have Karis in there I
can pull in a favorite grain boosting
library XG boost I can pull in a
plotting library
no I'm who here has had trouble getting
the right Python libraries installed
before and gone through a lot of
headaches around add okay probably about
a third of the audience which is
probably the third that seriously worked
with Python and a capacity before so
notice how by having this in docker and
having this ring on a cloud VM I remove
the installation pain from my work of
curiosity how many of you have seen or
worked with Jupiter notebooks before as
well quick show of hands okay great it
looks like about three-quarters of you
have for the quarter that haven't
Jupiter notebooks are a really nice tool
that have become the default IDE that
analysts and machine learning engineers
and DA scientists and that type use for
interactive data exploration they're
nice because they let you interleave
code markdown and the have graphic
results and visualization output side by
side in a seamless way but one of the
things that's tough with them by default
is versioning and one of the things
we've added to this is the ability to
hit a button then have a clean into in
version run create edge they can then
take that and share it with my teammates
they can fork it and reproduce it very
easily or I can click publish and share
that with the broader world another
extension that we've added on you'll see
if I type something like equals
hello next I'm surfacing my interactive
variables here so I know what I've
loaded into RAM and why I currently have
available to work with finally you will
see that I will have access to the same
set of data previews from that data set
they've loaded into this if I wanted to
do something like see what's my training
data or load that in I'm actually then I
can copy that I can see the histograms
for what's in it as well as a quick
preview of the data while I'm working
with it then pull that then use pandas
to load it into memory here
they see that I have that pulled into
memory now so we can continue to work
with that programmatically if I want to
I can drop in I can share this kernel
with my teammates who could start
working on it I could also add a GPU to
accelerate my analysis I could add
additional data sources if I want to
join to other data that might help me
with this problem I could reference both
public data that we have other
competitions datasets as well as the
output of any kernel that's been
published on data on coggle so far and
then finally if I have a use for having
an internet connection we do block
internet by default to encourage
reproducibility and reproducible
analytics workflows but I can easily
click another button and have it enabled
on this instance I want to step out of
the interactive environment now and drop
back into the benefits of having an
environment like this that's available
for our community
now they click through here for this
competition I can see hundreds and
hundreds of code examples that other
users have created and published on this
set
for example this user here made a really
helpful introduction to new users to
this problem for here's the data here's
a nice diagram and some details for how
the data is structured here is the
evaluation metric for my machine
learning model the R and D the ROC curve
as well as how that works here's how I
read into that that data into my
notebook here's some exploratory data
analysis consisting of things like how
to do one hot encoding to encode the
feature vectors they can use as an input
to my machine learning model as well as
here's some univariate relations for
example here's a distribution of how
likely people are to repay their loans
based on how old they are
it's not going to surprise us anyone
that younger people are slightly less
likely to repay their loans than older
people and then if I keep scrolling down
I continue to see that they this user
has done a very rich both exploratory
data analysis as well as has showed how
to trade a number of different machine
learning models on this data set
so when I start working with this
problem it's not like I'm starting with
just a raw data or an empty cursor I
have the benefits of all the work that
other users have created on the same
problem
that I can read those and leverage those
as a starting point I see here that this
kernel has been very popular over 200
people have loved comments on it this
users spray in 15 different versions of
it which I can click through and see if
I want to understand how he's developed
this over time how the different
versions have progressed as well as over
almost 2000 people have forked it and
then taking this and built on this and
use it as their own starting point you
make press fork what's happening is I'm
spinning up the same environment that
this user is using when he created the
kernel and then that makes it really
easy for me to reproduce his code so I
can go through here then I see no of
myself so run so far but they hit run
all its going to run this notebook top
to bottom it's going to start loading
into data and then I get the same set of
information that this user had created
available and reproducible with a click
of a button if you're asti how many of
you have had trouble reproducing work
that you found before either online or
in literature or some random good
example of a shared as like against a
github or etc yep it looks like most of
you have so my one of my goals over the
next five years is to make that zero
people raise their hands when I ask that
question again
then you see here this is kind of seem
to run through but this end-to-end
reproduction should work seamlessly
thanks to underlying technologies like
data versioning code versioning and
versioning the computational environment
through docker containers I when I click
out of this and that's a segue into the
next part of Cal our open data platform
so this part is a perfect tackle that we
launched about two years ago and in the
past two years our users have published
nearly 10,000 data sets on coggle many
of which are really high quality and
well curated assets that they've shared
with the world if you want to work with
your own data on Chicago it's really
easy click new to asset and then you can
buy there drag-and-drop files to upload
them you can use our API to polish them
directly from the command line and
you'll have a couple options as well
you'll put a title in you can choose
whether it's private or public many
users start off with private data then
keep it private as they're working on
their own side projects in hobbyist
projects for their own work many others
start private initially to upload it
work on it a little bit to clean it up
and then ultimately make it public to
the world and then just to give a couple
examples of the some of the different
types of data here you see that ranges
from New York City public data to things
like sports results - this is a good
computer vision data set for different
species of monkeys here and being able
to go through and identify the different
species of monkeys like this one
and if I want to pick different topics
and find out a appropriate for my
problem let's say I'm working in a
financial problem I might be interested
in stock data they can do a quick search
and see that there's over 100 data sets
that have different variations of both
us cetera national stock data another
area that's been popular recently is
Bitcoin so I can see that we have a
number of cryptocurrency datasets
available as well across several
different currencies if I'm trying to
train a computation model I might be
looking for image data source or search
for images and see what I have available
is a starting point there they could
also be say trying to train a sentiment
classifier on an LP prom that I can see
that there's hundreds of starting points
for our sentiment analysis and text
classification that I can take and
leverage I'll pull a couple of these up
in a bit more depth the first will be a
movie data set and then when I quicken
those stops at first I get can see very
quickly what's in the data itself in
this case
this one's metadata on almost 50,000
movies with 26 million ratings from over
270,000 users a click can go in a bit
more depth and see that it includes the
things I'd expect like who's in the
movie what's the cast and the crew a lot
of metadata with a movie for example
what's its budget how much money did it
make what language is it in here's a
quick summary of the movie how popular
it was a lot of things along those lines
and then as well as a rating status that
we're on the hundreds of thousands of
users rated these movies for on a scale
of one to five
then the other unique thing about
publishing data I'm Kyle or two other
unique things is first we version
everything by default so you don't have
to worry about versioning or if someone
you do an update to the data sets then
it's really easy to see that you did the
update and then to understand what
happened whether really common pain
points that we've seen is different
users or different teams are working on
different versions of the same data set
and aren't aware that they're working on
different versions of the same data set
so when it will change in one place but
not change it and the other or they'll
update the data set but not the
description and things like that so
whatever our goals is to make it really
easy to see when the data changed as
well as what changed with the data the
second thing is we have kernels
available on the assets as well and we
have a way to go through and for any
data set see all the code that's been
written and shared publicly on that data
set so again for any data that you
publish you don't just get the advantage
of here's a quick way to publish and
share data online we actually see the
results that users create on that and
the analysis that they create when user
Pierre trained a nice set of
recommendation engines and gave examples
of how to do both popularity based
content based and collaborative
filtering approaches to movie
recommendations in here and if I wanted
to take that and reproduce it and extend
it again I could click fork and run with
it
I'm just right for my browser there
another user whoops
open that twice another user here was
interested in some of the history of
film and looks back and at things such
as where did the movies originated from
and
what are some of the most popular and
highest-grossing movie franchises world
I'm so for answering questions like this
if I was I'm coming at this from another
angle I'd just be working with the Stas
that a random CSV file I downloaded off
the internet pulling it up locally then
doing all this analysis myself instead I
have the benefit of going through and
being able to see all the analyses that
other people have created on this so I
can both use this as an inspiration for
my own work and don't need to repeat
work that others have already done
another of my favorite public datasets
is one that we release ourselves so we
make all the data that we can't or most
of the data that we can make available
publicly on categories of things that
show up on the data sets and
competitions public versions of each of
those available to our users for
analytics so I can see things like
here's the CSV file of all the public
competitions that we've hosted or to get
a bit meta I can go in here and see
here's the different public data sets
that we have and I can actually find
this data set and does it here where I
see this little row represents that I
said that I'm currently seeing on this
page and we've really been blown away by
how all of our users have use this
whoops looks like this is down but this
is a really actively use data set we see
dozens and dozens of discussion and Alex
created on it each day two examples of
those
our one user wrote and automated colonel
to pull out where are all the winning
solutions of cago competitions many
users will publish their winning
solution and a forum post with a link to
the code that they used to create it so
this user went through and searched
pulled out for all of our popular
competitions here's the things that say
solution in the title ordered by number
of up votes the anti have activity on it
as a quick way to identify here's a list
of hundreds and hundreds of highly
competitive state-of-the-art machine
learning solutions that have been
created and she heard on goggle so if I
want to work on something like iceberg
classification for satellite images I
can come to this kernel I can click on
there the winning solution for that and
that I can quickly understand what is
the state of the art in this problem as
well as how did this team approach this
not just in theory but in practice how
did they segment the data and analyze it
and what do they do that work in a
similar vein another user realized that
we have a lot of people sharing really
helpful tutorials for how to do various
analytics machine learning and AI
projects and work on goggle and created
a si have topics and then pulled out
here's the best kernels on coggle for
each of these topics ranging from linear
regression logistic regression to extra
boost to deep learning and convolutional
neural networks to clustering algorithms
through to a lot of other things that
don't get a lot of buzz but are really
important for anyone applying helix and
machine learning in practice like doing
high-quality exploratory data analyses
so you understand what's actually in the
data side that you're working with and
how to do feature engineering
and components along those lines and
again whether cool things about this is
that this isn't that something that
today had to go through and may only
pull together instead they were able to
create this analyses our public data set
in a way that's automatically produced
and updated over time okay I'm gonna go
ahead and go into the last bit of cattle
for a little bit and then open up back
up for questions at the end we heard
from many of our newer users that they
really wanted more material to get
started and assigned some machine
learning so about six months ago we
launched a new section of kaggle called
cog allure and that's run through
kernels and then this is a set of about
ten different courses each of which
consists of around five to ten different
tutorials and exercises that take a a
week to go through covering areas like
I'm Python for analytics and machine
learning course using sequel as a data
scientist or here's how to get started
with your first machine learning models
I know go for these is to teach you just
enough they can use to get started with
your own machine learning work and then
to get you on to your own projects as
quickly as possible because we believe
that you learn the most from starting to
work in figuring out what works and what
doesn't on your own projects versus I'm
spending a lot of time following a very
structured course and curriculum so just
as one example of these for starting the
first machine learning project this is
on a we used post price prediction data
set for this where based on things like
how large how many square feet is in
your house and components like that how
many bedrooms do I've predict the sales
price of the home
and this is also something we're
considering how to take community
contributions from as well so if you're
inspired to use skagle as a teaching
platform then I'd be then I'd love to
speak to you afterwards um I encourage
you if you don't if there's an area of
analytics or data science or machine
learning that you want to explore more
of to check how to learn and to get
started there to start applying it to
your own work
[Music]
you